[Music]
ian braverman didn't want to see any
more closed signs go up in his
neighborhood
so he did something about it i came up
with this idea where i was like you know
it'd be great if i could see if there's
interest from the community
to help you know just give a small
donation a small gift to
all these hard-working people that you
know feed our community
that small act got a big response
fourteen thousand dollars in donations
to help
25 restaurants in his northbrook
illinois community
he really made my day nick drivis owner
of the grill house restaurant couldn't
believe it
when ian a complete stranger walked in
with a check
his act of kindness in doing that and
trying to help the restaurants
i mean i was when he came into my
restaurant i was kind of
overwhelmed with gratitude for what he
had done with federal aid lacking for
businesses hurt by the pandemic
ordinary people are stepping up in
watertown massachusetts employees and
customers raised nearly 50 thousand
dollars to keep this diner afloat
this restaurant in harrisburg
pennsylvania got a boost from community
donations
through a bar stool sports fundraiser it
makes me
feel that there is good humans in the
world there's people
that care about the everyday person
ian says pitching in during difficult
times is what americans do
just knowing that all these people are
they're hard workers this is their
livelihood
so we stand to lose these people that
have dedicated their life to things like
this
he believes without community support we
risk losing businesses that are
cornerstones
of our community